die schreibe ist jetzt nicht mehr in den
titel aber tatsächlich ist es jetzt
schon sehr wahrscheinlich dass
mindestens 40.000 menschen infiziert
sind wenn die maßnahmen in china
gegriffen haben so schnell hat sich in
den letzten jahren noch keine epidemie
ausgebreitet innerhalb von 48 stunden
haben sich die bestätigten fälle auf
6.000 verdoppelt und es gibt zusätzlich
noch 10.000 verdachtsfälle einfache
mathematik hilft jetzt zumindest im
verlauf der nächsten tage zu
prognostizieren ein führender deutscher
biologe fordert den sofortigen ausruf
des weltweiten gesundheitsnotfall es
klick zum science fiction gibt täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und activity glocke nur dann
verpasst er nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
dieses video habe ich heute morgen
aufgenommen in aller frühe weil ich
unterwegs bin vielleicht wurde der
weltweite gesundheitsnotfall schon
ausgerufen denn der ist laut dem
deutschen virologe alexander kekulé
überfällig die fallzahlen steigen
dramatisch und wir haben jetzt eine
ziemlich verlässliche größe mit heute
6000 infizierten vor zwei tagen waren es
noch 3000 alle 48 stunden verdoppeln
sich also die erkrankten das ganz große
problem dabei die infizierten sind im
schnitt zehn bis 14 tage ohne symptome
und steckten andere menschen an die
wiederum andere anstecken und so weiter
denn 2019 end seo wie der virus genannt
wird ist sofort ansteckend ohne symptome
ein riesiges problem und auch wenn die
bundesregierung beteuert darauf
vorbereitet zu sein
darauf kann man sich nicht vorbereiten
die infizierten sind quasi mindestens
zehn tage im schnitt getan nichts deutet
darauf hin dass sie träger des tödlichen
virus sind allerdings das ist auch
wichtig zu wissen
das virus ist nicht besonders tödlich
nicht ein drittel wie beim rs virus oder
zehn prozent wie bei saas sterben an der
infektion lediglich zwei prozent
überleben die infektion nach dem
jetzigen stand nicht allerdings wenn die
ausbreitung nicht gestoppt werden kann
dann können das in deutschland um die
eine million menschen sein und weltweit
rund 150 millionen das ist dann trotzdem
zehn mal so stark wie eine normale
grippe so alexander kekulé das ist
vergleichbar mit der spanischen grippe
die zwischen 1918 und 1920 in mehreren
wellen zwischen 25 und 70 millionen
menschen getötet hat so genau weiß man
das nicht bei einer deutlich geringeren
bevölkerung doch damals gab es keinen
flugverkehr das heißt die infektion
konnte sich nicht ganz so schnell
verbreiten
trotzdem ging es dann doch relativ
schnell weil soldaten im ersten
weltkrieg aus den usa wo die solche
ausgebrochen war in kriegsschiffen nach
europa geschickt wurden und man war rein
gar nicht auf eine solche pandemie
vorbereitet heute ist die situation
deutlich besser aber eben das phänomen
der ansteckung ohne symptome macht es
extrem schwierig die ausbreitung
einzudämmen in den usa halten fachleute
die ausbreitung des virus dort für
wahrscheinlich und der virologe
alexander kekulé sieht auch für
deutschland die solche als nahezu
unaufhaltbar an zitat in china ist die
seit 2003 bekannte lungenkrankheit sars
wieder ausgebrochen
nicht mehr und nicht weniger schreibt er
im berliner tagesspiegel weber findet
ihr die quellen in der video
beschreibung erfordert sofortige
einreisekontrollen für alle fluggäste
aus china
dafür gibt es einen zuverlässigen test
allerdings ist das virus schon hier und
kann schon rund 100 menschen angesteckt
haben ja zu den zahlen komme ich noch
gleich und wie man das aus rechnet und
er fordert die sofortige ausrufung des
internationalen gesundheitsnotfall ist
und jetzt zu den zahlen und darf zu
brauchen wir als grundlage lediglich die
6000 sichert infizierten vorgestern lag
diese zahl noch bei 3000 davon ausgehend
wissen wir nach aktuellem stand dass
sich die zahl aller 48 stunden
verdoppelt sprich wenn es keine
quarantäne gibt städte nicht abgeriegelt
werden das virus sich also ungehemmt
ausbreiten kann steckt es alle 48
stunden noch mal so viele menschen an
wie bereits infiziert sind das heißt
hochrechnet sind es momentan mindestens
knapp 40.000 menschen die sich
angesteckt haben und wie vor zwei videos
erwähnt der expertin die verrissen vom
imperial college landen vermutet
hunderttausende infizierte die 40.000
sind zurückhaltend gerechnet mit einer
niedrigen inkubationszeit von zehn tagen
also dass sie nicht so lange andere
anstecken können und nur für die
nächsten fünf tage danach wurde ja also
vor zehn tagen ein gebiet mit mehr als
50 millionen einwohnern abgeriegelt und
der autoverkehr verboten theoretisch
müsste sich die ausbreitung danach
verlangsamt theoretisch allerdings in
allen ländern mit momentan niedrigen
fallzahlen ist das ja noch nicht der
fall
dort wird sich das virus voraus die sich
weiter mit hohem tempo ausbreiten
allerdings
bei so niedrigen zahlen ist das
unkalkulierbar und von vielen zufällen
abhängig in deutschland können das also
ausgehend von im moment vier infizierten
inzwischen mehr als 100 infizierte seien
jeder und jede kann sich ausrechnen wann
die gesamte bevölkerung deutschlands
theoretisch infiziert wäre aber das ist
wirklich nur spekulation für den fall
dass es durchschnittlich abläuft und es
bleibt zu hoffen dass die
sensibilisierung vor allem von menschen
die aus china hierher geflogen sind
dafür sorgt dass sie sehr vorsichtig
sind und im fall der fälle deutlich
weniger menschen anstecken
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn hat
den corona virus mit dem ausbruch einer
schweren grippe verglichen
da sterben in deutschland so rund 20.000
menschen im jahr allerdings und das ist
der unterschied alle menschen haben
antikörper gegen zahlreiche grippe viren
im blut bei 2009/10 nc und v ist das
wohl nicht der fall darüber ob sich
menschen nicht anstecken und immun sind
gibt es allerdings bisher keinerlei
informationen wir haben eine playlist
dazu gemacht mit aktuellen updates also
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
da packen wir jeweils das aktuelle video
rein und nur dann wenn er also abonniert
habe verpasst er nichts bis dann bleibt
dran